[Música]
hola con todos
ya lo dijo platón
hay que tener el valor para decir la
verdad sobre todo cuando se habla de la
verdad y la verdad sea dicha aquí arriba
en este mismo momento estoy siendo presa
de un pánico escénico
y los que me conocen van a decir bueno
pero si tú te has pasado casi la mitad
de tu vida subiendo y bajando de los
escenarios pero qué pasa que es difícil
el pánico de ser y como viene cuando
tengo que hablar de mí mismo en primera
persona y singular
sin vestuarios y maquillaje o sea si un
libreto memorizado o sea no estoy muy
acostumbrada así que bueno
para dar estas charlas me dijeron que
habían reglas muy estrictas primero a
gustarme el tiempo y luego no salirme de
la alfombra roja
pero yo estoy siendo presa del pánico
pero por fortuna es por el agua
bueno acá hay un reloj que con marcha
atrás
parece una de esas bombas programadas
que tienen un ritmo casi y llegar a ser
hacia de esas películas románticas de
terroristas explota y bueno ya hemos
estado pasando bien para que no causa
ningún accidente aquí
empecemos
mi nombre es luis me dicen mucho y soy
luchó y patucho
así suena hasta remando de romántico se
alegre
y aquí mi país el ecuador los bajos de
estatura se le dice para techos de allí
el apelativo y ha buscado en todas
partes de donde como porque es el eso
nos dicen pachuchos no encontrado nada
si alguien lo encuentre por favor que me
diga lo que se ha encontrado son
sinónimos gentilicios en otros países
tales como petizos retan contacto enano
liliputiense cuarto de litro
en mi barrio los pastos dicen cuarto de
litro
si yo hubiera nacido en un país europeo
fuera diferente porque proyecto fuera
picudo
de 'twitter'
qué
o sí
ustedes se ríen pero para mí siempre
esto fue un conflicto ser pequeño de
estatura
pero quiero contarles cómo los hallazgos
me hicieron definir el teatro y la danza
hallazgos surgidos de obstáculos y el
primero pues obviamente mi tamaño y de
cómo me adapte a ello para lograr el
cambio porque ya sabemos que no es el
más fuerte el más inteligente el que es
el que sobrevive sino aquel que es capaz
de adaptarse a los carnés cuando fui por
primera vez a la escuela yo tenía 5 años
fue un cambio tremendo para mí al cual
tuve que adaptarme en casa yo era el
pequeño y el con chito de la familia el
mimado de mamá era normal pero cuando
llegué a la escuela era el fenómeno
yo no era un niño era el niño spatuzza y
en el curso había muchos pactos bello en
el patio más patrulla de todos los
patios era terrible porque los más
grandes siempre te quedan mirando así
uno tiene que mirarlos hacia arriba acá
a la hora de entrar y hacer la fila para
entrar en el aula de clase este había
que tomar distancia
y bueno todos lo usaban como bastón
y yo tratando alcanzar el hombre que
estaba delante parece que estaba
saludando al tercer reich así era
terrible
entonces el pequeño este estudio me
causó muchos conflictos de autoestima
hasta el punto que me daba un miedo
atroz salir al recreo la hora del recreo
sonaba la campana para salir al recreo y
60 niños a la vez salían desaforados
como lava contenida en un volcán como
animales puesto en libertad como locos
en un manicomio que tiene una puerta
abierta y al guardia dormido salían
además a su paso lo tiraban todo
incluyéndome
y las pocas veces que yo salí de recreo
los compañeritos jugaban a la ronda luz
sopa tuzzio mató a su mujer la iso
chorizo jirafa vende a que por más
tierno que pareciera el canto era un
claro bulling disfrazado de ronda
infantil además me estaban incriminando
por un crimen que yo no había cometido
ni mujer tenía era muy pequeño entonces
me quedaba en la soledad y en el
silencio del aula con el olor de la tiza
con el olor de los de los lápices
sacados así puntas
con esos testigos hablaba solo recitaba
cantaba jugaba con personajes inventados
en un estrado porque el 2 antes las
escuelas tenían estrados al pie de la
pizarra ya hasta que un día la señorita
sofía a una de esas maestras que no
tiene cuando es niño lo más parecidas
hadas madrinas entró y me descubrió
debió haberme visto por largo rato
porque no se atrevió a producir me hasta
que yo terminaba la última estrofa de la
canción y la última recitación teniendo
el récord la señorita sofía sin pensarlo
dos veces me animó a recitar y a cantar
en la obra social de los viernes en el
patio central del colegio frente a todos
es la escuela y allí a pesar del miedo
hice mi primer hallazgo
la entrega colectiva de chicos y chicas
profesores escuchando emocionados y supe
que eso era bueno mi soledad y mis
silencios se habían transformado pasar
algunos años cambie de escuela nuevos
cursos nuevos compañeros nueva escuela
igual estatura
nueve años y me tropecé con otras formas
de bullying la de los cachos la de los
golpes la zancadilla pero un día leyendo
en el texto escolar hice un segundo
hallazgo una forma maravillosa de
escritura donde alguien ponía de manera
jocosa lo que otros tenían que decir y
hacer línea tras línea ocurrencia trans
ocurrencia
una comedia sencilla costumbrista a los
sordos de un maestro y escritor
argentino germán bardales pero no les
hago el cuento largo ya una voz interna
mi pecho y en mi cerebro me llevó hasta
la oficina de la dirección donde la
señorita sofía la directora puse las
narices en su escritorio y le dije
quiero hacer un grupo de teatro con mis
compañeritos de grados ya a los que
dicho sea de paso en este año recién
después de décadas los he vuelto a
encontrar viejo
la señorita sofía que es también que era
también como otra de esas hadas madrinas
que no siempre se encuentra en la
escuela la presión a excelente idea y
nos dio lugar de tiempo no destino las
condiciones para poder ensayar y se le
ocurre una excelente idea presentar la
obra de teatro en el día de la fiesta de
la navidad antes de la coronación de la
princesita de navidad entonces el día
del estreno
padres de familia alumnos profesores no
solamente aplaudiendo que se pusieron de
pie
y se sentía en el ambiente que aquello
era algo nuevo y que nos pertenecía a
todos y que creen a partir de ese día
nunca más recibió una burla nunca más
una coca echó una zancadilla se produjo
así la maravilla de un nuevo hallazgo
supe que eso era bueno porque el teatro
me mostraba una fortaleza intrínseca
mágica potente que lograba el cambio de
las personas
la suerte entonces estuvo echada de esos
primeros días de mini es el teatro fue
mi gran motivación búsqueda realización
nunca más me sentí pequeño la estructura
no fue frontera para el viaje de los
sueños hasta la fecha ese recuerdo me
hace entender que los obstáculos sean
palabras personas situaciones pueden
vencerse cuando uno desea cumplir un
propósito una meta una acción y que los
deseos se planifican desde acá en la
máquina de hacer ideas consciente o
inconscientemente voluntario
involuntariamente que los sueños llegan
hasta donde uno quiere proyectarnos pasó
el tiempo a firmar a finales de mis
estudios secundarios con casi 20 años
cumplidos decidí irme del país a buscar
la formación de actor que yo quería
información que no existía en ese
entonces en la ciudad dejé la vida
universitaria cómoda de estudiante de
literatura trabajé en varios oficios
como guionista de televisión como
despachador de estación de gasolina
ahorre todo el dinero posible
estaba decidida pero esa decisión me
costó
me gustó bastante la separación con mi
padre que no estaba de acuerdo del yo el
último y sus hijos varones se
convirtiera en actor y no en médico el
médico que él sus padres no lo habían
permitido ser obligándolo estudiar otra
carrera más productiva el comercio
recuerdo que a punto de graduarme en un
almuerzo dominical estamos todos
sentados y alguien preguntó y que fue en
lo que va a estudiar luchó y yo
aproveché la oportunidad de decirle
teatro
un ambiente tenso mi papá nos alcanzó
meterse la cuchara en la boca y la
tensión se podía cortar un cuchillo y
alguien dijo entonces cuando hagas tu
primera película me dijo un primer papel
y otra mi hermana y yo sí pero una
película de terror
todos los recibos pero mi padre se
levantó serio excepcional por mucho
tiempo la vimos en un distanciamiento
que duró años en méxico ella y méxico me
di cuenta que los exámenes de admisión
para las escuelas de artes escénicas
eran muy riguroso y yo no estaba
dispuesto a que nada interrumpiera mi
deseo así que vi que muchos no podían
llegar al examen de expresión corporal
de lo que yo nunca había aprendido así
que decidí tomar cursos talleres antes
de expresión corporal que me tocó un
gran maestro mexicano coreógrafo raúl
flores canelo él también es como un hada
madrid pero con pantalones
y me decía que mis ejercicios eran
diferentes y me instó en los pasillos
métete estudiar danza en la escuela de
bellas artes lo hice ya y a pesar de mí
unos cincuenta y picos de estatura pase
el examen de lesión y ahí
tuve otro ya sus orgulloso que fue el
descubrimiento de la danza contemporánea
provocando adaptaciones más increíbles
en mi cuerpo pequeño ya aprendí a ser
efectivo en el movimiento transitando
por cambios fisiológicos ritmos
corporales uso del espacio manejo de la
energía etcétera a veces tengo en cuenta
que las personas en las personas el
cuerpo humano está en peligro de
extinción por lo menos en cuanto a
movimiento se está maravillosa
herramienta que nos hace diferentes e
iguales a la vez este conjunto de
sistemas orgánicos que proyectan nuestra
forma de ser y estar
pero no solamente por los factores del
sedentarismo sino el excesivo uso de la
palabra porque puede porque preferimos
decir que hacer
y le damos rienda suelta a nuestros
bloqueos a través de protocolos códigos
costumbres pero han relegado a su mínima
expresión en las escuelas en las
oficinas en las casas la energía
universal del movimiento desperdiciar
por eso para aquellos aquellos que
abrazamos las artes escénicas como la
danza el teatro el mismo si es nuestro
cuerpo el principal maestro porque es
como un laboratorio incorporado que
alguno trae ya que no sólo se reinventa
por las disciplinas y los estilos con
los cuales nos entrenamos sino que se
reinventa cada vez que tiene que
adaptarse por personas cosas o
situaciones familiares y hay que estar
atentos a ellos
o sea además de usarlo para sentarnos
caminar pararnos etc el cuerpo
y a veces los bailarines también
corremos con el tiempo el peligro de
hacerlo de que el cuerpo se pierda
solamente en la tragedia
desoyendo el lado lúdico del cuerpo en
san jose costa rica mientras un
sociólogo de la universidad viendo la
compañía de danza blavia una danza
profundamente energética existencial con
un gran predominio de golpes arrastradas
ya gritos ahí das
a la salida no dijo porque ustedes los
bailarines de danza contemporáneos
sufren tanto
y me di cuenta de que era razón
nos dejamos arrastrar el divismo de la
tragedia
y no digo que esté mal pero se descuida
pues la parte dionisíaca de la expresión
del cuerpo hacia a través de
conversaciones llegamos obviamente
replantear y adaptar con una compañera
liliana álvarez los temas de la danza la
percusión nos propusimos danzas con
temas con toques de ironía
planteamientos absurdos ficciones
apegadas a personajes y situaciones
reales más aterrizadas con nuestra
realidad urbana latinoamericana si
quiere y así fue el hallazgo de la danza
y el humor
así fue el nacimiento de saragó esta
agrupación que ahora llega a los 30 años
de vida que en guayaquil
y me da mucho gusto ver en esta sala a
mucha gente joven porque de estas
charlas quiero espero no haberme
equivocado usando estas secuelas de
anécdotas ya personales quiero concluir
diciéndoles que nuestro cuerpo por
pequeño que sea es un gigante
ni la soledad y el silencio de la
violencia disfrazada de juegos cándidos
con condicionantes o sabotajes para
nuestros proyectos
además que depende de repente bien entre
aquellos que más los aman se haga un
impedimento jóvenes y focalizan su
carrera a través de las artes de la
danza o el teatro ya
a veces viene sugerida por pequeños
intangibles hallazgos conforme en el
camino atrás en el camino and en el
camino no la meta protejan el sueño
saquen a pasear guarden lo de repente en
el armario pero abren las puertas
nuevamente
permite hacer caminar con él porque los
caminos están colmados de adaptaciones y
áreas y los otros madres padres más
maestros a redescubrir nuestro verdadero
rol de guía sin temor a ser hadas
madrinas colaborando apareciendo como
maduros que somos los sueños de los
noveles que tenemos que colaborar con
eso espero que me disculpen por haber
trabajo hablado de mí mismo porque bueno
como dijo bertold brech hablo de mí
mismo porque el primer ser humano que
tengo a la mano
entonces
espero que tengamos otra oportunidad
para seguir conversando obviamente en
otro lugar por ejemplo en el lado oscuro
de la luna' una vez de pegar a mi madre
observó que yo estaba mirando una luna
llena y me dijo que mira yo digo porque
la luna es como un queso lleno de
agujeros y me dijo que era un queso y
que los agujero eran porque un conejo se
los comía tamayo loca
pero divertida a mi madre yo dije bueno
y dónde está el conejo dice del otro
lado porque al otro lado es la calle no
se puede ver a nadie a nada porque es el
lado oscuro de la luna y lo que más vive
al lado oscuro de la luna me dijo los
coroneles con los animales los duendes
los actores los bailarines la gente del
circo
[Risas]
será por eso que ese lado nunca puede
verse lo que tiene porque algo tiene que
quedar que nunca se haya visto por favor
en el universo algo en donde uno puede
reinventarse donde haya mucho tiempo y
espacio para adaptarse súbitamente poco
a poco aunque uno mida 1,50 y pico
y ahora como mi edad
[Aplausos]
no logré
gracias